hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skincare nerd and asian i don't
know why that's my intro but i've committed if
you're into skincare you'll know that there's lots
of hype around asian skincare particularly korean
and japanese products and it's not hard to see why
korean and japanese skincare have lots of product
types that you don't really see with western
brands and they tend to be really affordable but
there are so many products that it can get a bit
overwhelming and because a lot of the time you
need to get these products shipped from overseas
and it can be hard to track them down and
it's hard to get them all from the one site
a lot of sites only stock particular brands and so
sometimes you need to buy products from multiple
sites and then the shipping can all add up so
i was really excited when stylvana asked me to
partner with them on a sponsored video they have
a ridiculously large range of asian beauty brands
they're like a one-stop shop and they have a
pretty low total for free shipping they let me
pick whatever products i wanted from their range
to review and they also gave me a discount code
this gives you 15 off selected brands and 10 off
everything else so i picked out a bunch of really
hyped up products that i've always wanted to try
and i'm going to review them today if you like
talking nerdy about the science behind beauty
products click the like the subscribe and the
notification bell so you don't miss any videos
i'm going to start with the rohto melano cc this
is probably the vitamin c product that i
have read the most about that got me the most
excited it is a japanese product and in japan this
is actually regulated as a quasi drug it came with
a long instruction sheet which is all in japanese
so thank you google translate for helping me out a
lot on this video this is an ascorbic acid product
now ascorbic acid is the version of vitamin c that
has the most evidence behind it but it's also a
pain it goes off really easily it oxidizes it goes
brown and it's one of the reasons why you hear
that vitamin c serums a lot of the time you can
only use them for about three months before you
have to chuck them out ascorbic acid can also be
quite irritating because it is acidic and so a
lot of the time it's just not really worth the
bother for people one of the ways that this gets
around this oxidation issue is the packaging it's
really innovative i haven't actually seen this
type of packaging before it has this sort of
metered packaging and you can see if i squeeze it
no matter how hard you squeeze it it only comes
out one drop at a time and so that means it's
really hard for air to go back into the product
and so yeah that's how it keeps the vitamin c
stable for so long and i've had this for a while
now i think i've had this for maybe two months and
it is still completely clear there is zero brown
going on a lot of other people have also said that
they've had this for a while and they haven't seen
it go brown they've seen the bits around the
thread go brown but not the actual product
coming out it's also meant to be a spot treatment
which is why it comes out so slowly but it does
spread really easily so it's not that hard to get
enough out that you can get it all over your face
there are other ingredients inside it apart from
the ascorbic acid there's vitamin e also potassium
glycerizate which is listed as an anti-acne
ingredient it's one of the active ingredients
in licorice extract and it's anti-inflammatory
there's also an ingredient i haven't come across
before which is isopropyl methylphenol it
is meant to be antibacterial so this seems
to target two of the factors that can help with
acne so inflammation and bacteria according to the
packaging there's also a delivery system with this
which helps these active ingredients penetrate
your skin a bit deeper this has a slippery
oil-like texture it sinks in pretty quickly it
leaves a very very slightly tacky finish i found
this to be one of the least irritating ascorbic
acid products i've ever tried and it has just
the mildest of scents i've been using this for
my post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation which i've
been getting from masks and also from trying out a
lot of sunscreens and it's been working really
well now speaking of sunscreens sunscreens are
probably some of the most popular asian skincare
products and that's because i think they have such
a light texture wearing sunscreen daily has been
coming in asia for ages it's been decades and so
there are lots of lightweight asian sunscreens
that you're meant to wear under makeup so it's
important to note that a lot of asian sunscreens
aren't intended for like hardcore wear unless
they're specifically water resistant they're not
really designed to protect you while you're going
out and being sweaty and moving around a lot so
if you're gardening if you're exercising if you're
going on a bike ride or going to the beach these
are probably not going to be that suitable they're
really like commuter sunscreens you're only meant
to wear them to and from the office and maybe when
you're heading off to go buy lunch but there are
some water resistant asian sunscreens which have
really nice textures and these can stand up
to a bit more activity water resistant means
that they've been tested in water so they've been
applied to people the people had to sit in water
and then after they got out after a certain amount
of time they tested how much protection was left
but they do still say to reapply if you sweat a
lot if you get into the water if you rub it off
with a towel and that's because no sunscreen is
like a barrier that you never have to reapply they
do still break down and that's why the legislation
got rid of the word waterproof because they're not
really waterproof they just hold up better
so today i'm going to be talking about three
water-resistant asian sunscreens that i've tried
and i actually really liked the first one is biore
uv's watery essence i reviewed this back in 2014
on my blog but they kept on reformulating it so
it seems like they do it every two years so like
2015 2017 2019 and so theoretically they should be
reformulating it this year as well it's kind of
annoying because it means you can't really rely
on all reviews and you always have to be really
careful about checking what year they're from it
can also be hard to work out which version you're
buying especially because there is that language
barrier but i also really respect that they care
enough to keep on reformulating a product to be
better and better even though the old product
was doing so well like in the old versions this
is spf 50 plus and pa with four pluses which is
the highest protection level you can get in japan
this uses a whole bunch of the newer filters and
interestingly they don't have titanium dioxide
in a lot of asian sunscreen there is titanium
dioxide and unfortunately this can give a white
cast what's new in the 2019 version is that they
have the micro defense formula which they say is
a world first and what's really interesting to me
is that in their press release they actually say
that the reason they started looking into this
innovation was because they weren't happy with
their old formula according to them their all
water-based formulas didn't actually perform
that well so their all water-based formulas
didn't always apply evenly so when you zoomed
in there were all these microscopic cracks plus
they weren't sweat and shaving resistant so
some of the sunscreen ingredients would come off
quite easily so this uses tiny capsules which are
smaller than micron size and these capsules
contain an oil-soluble sunscreen ingredient
and they deliver it so that it applies really
evenly so this gives higher coverage while
still keeping that lightweight texture this has 80
minutes water resistance and along with the other
two sunscreens which i'm going to talk about in
a sec it has one of the nicest textures i've ever
tried in a water-resistant sunscreen this does
have lots of alcohol in it it wasn't a problem
for me it didn't feel like it dried out my skin at
all and i think that's because it's also got lots
of hydrating ingredients in it i found that this
didn't sting my eyes as long as i didn't actually
rub it straight into my open eye this has a light
floral scent and i found that when i rubbed it on
my skin it peeled a little bit which is pretty
standard for water resistant sunscreens but
with this one it wasn't very much at all the next
sunscreen is the skin aqua uv super moisture gel
this is from rohto which is the same brand
as the melano cc this feels very similar to
the biore sunscreen but i had zero peeling with
it it has a really fantastically light texture
it's water resistant and it is also fragrance
free i love that it comes in a large pack size
which is larger than pretty much every asian
sunscreen i've tried it's larger than a lot of
facial sunscreens from western brands as well and
it has a pump bottle which is super super handy
now the downside is that i found that this done
my eyes quite a lot if i put it on my eyes so
the first time i tried it around my eyes i was
actually about to go driving and i was driving
while like crying out of one eye so don't do that
other people have said that this doesn't sting
their eyes so it might work for you but yeah don't
try it out right before driving now this does also
have a ton of alcohol but it doesn't feel drying
so i think that's because they've also put lots of
glycerin hyaluronic acid hydrolyzed collagen in it
but the alcohol will kind of whack you in the nose
now onto my favorite sunscreen of the three this
is the anessa perfect uv sunscreen skincare milk
last year i tried their mild milk which
my friend larry gave to me in singapore
right before 2020 really set in unfortunately my
skin hated the mild milk i found that when i put
it on it seemed to shift around endlessly without
really setting in and so my makeup sort of bunched
up all over the place and it just looked really
gross and greasy i think it's partly because i
have oily skin and partly because i live in
sydney which is quite humid and so that sort
of silly coney product just doesn't really set now
i've talked to some people with dry skin and they
love that sort of texture so if you have dry
skin then the mild milk might work for you that
one also clogged the crap out of my pores but this
one this is the 20 20 version of the skincare milk
it is in a slightly darker gold bottle and it has
a blue top so be really careful if you're buying
a nessa sunscreen double check the name and double
check the packaging so you don't buy the wrong one
this is a combination sunscreen that seems to
contain like every sunscreen filter this is 80
minutes water resistant it's also rub resistant
sweat resistant heat resistant apparently it
spreads even better if you have heat this is
also apparently mask stuffiness resistant which
is like the most 20 20 claim i have no idea how
they tested that i found that this doesn't peel
it gives me no eye irritation and it works super
well under makeup it's a fantastic makeup primer
now this is my favorite of the three but it is
also the most expensive of the three now last
time i checked the skin aqua was the cheapest of
the three per ml but the biore comes in a smaller
pack size so this ends up being cheaper to buy
if you just want to buy one product i also tried
the some by mi aha bha pha 30 days miracle acne
clear body cleanser i chose this product because
i was excited to see a body acne product because i
destroyed my hair for fashion i have to use really
heavy hair conditioners and a lot of the time they
stay on my back and they clog my pores and so i
get a lot of back acne the best way to deal with
that is to wash my back really thoroughly in the
shower but that can be really difficult because
i'm also kind of buff and so it can be hard to
reach back there i just found that this cleansing
is so easy to use it's obviously in a huge bottle
it has a pump chop which is always convenient it
foams up really well and it rinses away really
well in terms of ingredients it's got 10 000 parts
per million tea tree oil which translates to about
one percent there's also aha 0.5 percent salicylic
acid and pha i don't know if it's the active
ingredients or just the fact that it's a really
effective cleanser or probably a combination
of both but i've been using this for about six
weeks and i've seen a lot less back acne it's not
stripping on my skin i don't feel any tightness
afterwards and it hasn't been irritating but it
is also summer in sydney so i'm looking forward
to trying this out in winter and seeing if that's
still the case so interestingly after i tried it
i looked at the ingredients and there were some
soap like ingredients in it so i tested the ph
and it turns out the ph is actually quite high
so it's 9 to 10. usually i avoid soap surfactants
and high ph cleansers but i think in this case it
was actually really effective i think maybe the
high ph actually helped wash away conditioner
because hair conditioner is acidic a lot of the
time if you have an acidic thing it's easy to wash
it away with a basic thing so maybe i was playing
myself all along by using only low ph cleanses on
my back maybe my back did actually need a high ph
cleanser and that high ph was counteracted with
how effective it is so i don't know this
works really well for me i also picked up
a little trio of remind lip products i got a
whole bunch of recommendations for this brand
after i complained about how hard it was to find
brick coloured lipsticks in western stores this
collection is called the best tint edition and
it is the warm tone version there are two types
of products in the pack the first type is the
zero velvet tint which is like a matte lipstick
and then after the matte lipstick wears off
then you're left with a really pretty tint
the other products are the juicy lasting tints
and these are sort of like a pretty pigmented lip
gloss and again they leave behind a really nice
tint these give you a much more natural look this
is more of a solid lipstick look unlike a lot
of lip tints i've tried in the past these are
really moisturizing and they don't really cling to
dry patches as badly this is really important for
me because i have pretty fat lips and so i find
that they tend to dry out really easily and i
always have dry patches so not highlighting these
dry patches is pretty important i've been really
enjoying wearing these under a mask because they
tend to last a bit longer than lip products so
if i know i'm going to be wearing a mask for a
long time and i want to look good after i take
it off i put on one of these and then i let
it sort of stain a bit and then i blot it off
a bit put on a clear lip gloss or a lip balm
and then put the mask on and so that gives me
i guess a bit of a shield over the long lasting
color these also look really good on their own
and at the moment i'm actually wearing this one
which is number thirteen eat dotori don't really
tend to wear these sorts of products much on
camera but i wear them all the time in real life
i find that these are sometimes a bit shiny and so
they don't look as good on camera and having more
pigmented products actually looks better on camera
so this one is actually a little bit darker in
real life there is also a lighter one which is the
jujube this one looks a little bit more natural
this is a little bit more dramatic but yeah more
dramatic than it currently looks the juicy lasting
tints are definitely the ones i like more they're
really hydrating they keep my lips looking nice
and it's really easy to reapply it feels like
you're just reapplying lip gloss with the zero
velvet tin i find that the matte look it looks a
little bit five years ago with the matte lipstick
craze but after you either blot it off or if you
put on a clear lip gloss over it then it looks
really good i'm not that good at makeup and so i
haven't really mastered the gradient lip look so
i'm sure there are lots of people using this matte
one really amazingly but on me i can't make a look
anything other than straight up 2015. so i hope
you like this video i hope my reviews were helpful
have you tried any of these products let
me know what you think in the comments
don't forget you can use the discount code if
you want to pick up anything from stylevana
if you like the video click the like and
the subscribe you can also follow me on
instagram and check out my blog for more beauty
science see you next time to nerd out more